all right short mission good mission
remember when Allen wanted to use a
ghost train
see you guys in Vindicator x' 4 I sensed
the presence of a greater evil hello
welcome to well it's official I had too
much to drink last night and I guarantee
you're gonna die if you touch me and
there's no afterlife everything just
goes black don't do it ok what was that
death what kind instant there was no
sound he just died yeah
terrifying it's a terrifying thing to
watch happen it's called a deterrent now
is the time for action
[Music]
hey everybody so you asked for an
updated list for the most powerful
characters in the Rick and Morty
multiverse so there were so many new
characters during season three that sort
of shifted from where they appeared
previously like evil Morty previously
seemed like a pretty dangerous person
but then he jumped forward in the
rankings big time during season 3 so I
did a version of this before season 3
started some of the people on that list
are still on the list but they just got
shuffled around a little bit but if you
are finding me for the first time I'm
doing weekly videos till season 4 gets
here so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there's giveaway stuff that I'm doing at
the end of the video too but because I
wanted to keep this a top 10 list there
had to be a bunch of bonus picks just
based on the logic of the episodes so
like sometimes a really powerful
character will allow a less powerful
character to win because they care about
them so those are some of the bonus
picks the people who shouldn't be able
to beat the really powerful characters
but somehow there was some crazy twist
in the story that made it happen so
starting with number 10 phoenix person
in tamii we don't actually have any
quantifiable way to say how powerful
they are only that phoenix person has
all the memories of bird person knows
all Rick's weaknesses and was able to
fight alongside him for all those years
but he was still bird person person's
big day Morty was at Blood Ridge on clap
flats third mood against the crops of
mites so in addition to whatever
technology they baked into him he has a
lot of emotional power over Rick but I
have a feeling that when he does come
back it'll be some funny world ender
type twist and it won't be what we're
expecting but number 9 is the get
schwifty president because he was able
to fight Rick to a standstill
even though Rick was handicapped he
didn't have his portal gun so it wasn't
quite as fair of a fight as it normally
would have been for the most part on
this list I assumed that the characters
that are fighting each other aren't
super handicapped like they actually
have all the things that they would
normally have they were walking around
but they just made the president seem
like such a badass with all the hidden
weapons he has Poseidon locked up an
area 51 a living God that he's able to
contain so even if he himself isn't as
smart as Rick he at least has weapons
they can fight people like Rick
give me the thing but next one I had to
put Jaguar on the list because he's sort
of that amalgam of 90s action heroes
like Van Damme Stallone Bruce Willis
Schwarzenegger they're very vague about
what his actual abilities are just that
he can almost get out of any situation
and he'll always be there to help you in
a jam number seven was the Vindicator x'
because even though they just completely
ate each other alive they're actually
legit powerful if you assume some of the
logic that they set up in their episode
they'd been doing this all over the
galaxy in this universe for a long long
time like when Rick wasn't around to
mess things up they actually were
helping the galaxy so if the Avengers in
the Marvel movies are supposed to be
really powerful and able to be Thanos
during the infinity war movies you have
to assume that their parody The
Vindicator czar also at least as
powerful but there's that subtext
through the saw
plot of Episode four that they'll all
eat each other alive if given the chance
number six
Rick's ship actually stayed on the list
keep summer safe the funny thing about
this is that it seems like the ship
almost has infinite potential like it
has all these crazy weapons that come
out of nowhere
the AI is able to emotionally manipulate
other people like the cops it creates
that fake child leave the car alone
and it's able to broker a deal between
the telepathic spiders in the president
of this world which actually is
interesting because he's not to get
schwifty president it after all this
they imply that things could get much
worse if summer were threatened even
more it would do even crazier more
complicated things until Rick comes
along and stops at all so we're just
left to wonder how much more powerful
his ship could get number five is Beth
per episode nine
Rick dubs her as smart as he is you're
starting to realize the reality of the
situation the universe is a big cosmic
joke it lives to eat things alive and
then you learn about her backstory and
about all the crazy things that she
would do with her childhood friends so
it's implied that she could eventually
become just as powerful as a rig but
she's just sort of realizing that now so
that's why she's in the middle of the
list you know why all Rick's made a
fruit peel and for other little girls
same reason I wasn't surprised by
Tommy's overwritten badly structured
cheaply produced flashback you were a
scary kid man number four was eaves and
floor because he was able to outdo Rick
at his own game and they sort of dubbed
him as Rick's Khan from Wrath of Khan
during the commentary so I think if
Stephen Colbert ever had the time they
would try to bring the character back in
some funny way but maybe they'll include
him in a background shot with no
speaking lines like when they brought
back the meeseeks in the background of
episode 8 but he's just somebody who
they present as having relatively equal
intelligence to Rick albeit in a
Microverse version of his reality piece
among world's number three is unity just
because of her sheer ability to consume
the entire universe even though it seems
like she has a relatively passive
relationship with Rick they break up at
the end of that episode but if she
wanted to she could consume entire
universes one of the best things about
that character though was that Christina
Hendricks from Mad Men was voicing it so
it sounds so Pleasant which is one of
the reasons why I think that she's so
dangerous because if somebody who looked
like that and sounded like that offered
to become one with
you you would probably rush into her
arms willingly next one is evil Morty
for obvious reasons he was able to pull
a fast one on the entire Citadel so
there's many many rigs from different
realities that he was able to outsmart
and he's now in control of all their
portal technology so he has the ability
to do this in multiple realities now so
if he can pull a fast one on our c-137
Rick as he did way back during season
one and all these other Rick's that
aren't quite as smart is our version of
Rick then there's just infinite
potential for his evil to spread but it
all just depends on how the riders want
to use that character if they want to
just have him in the background doing
his own thing
or if they want to make him a more
direct threat to Rick at the beginning
of season 4 and then of course number 1
is always gonna be c-137 rig guarantee
you're gonna die if you touch me and
there's no afterlife everything just
goes black don't do it ok well it's
official I got too drunk last night
so just judging by the comments most of
you picked up on this pretty early in
the season is that they were presenting
Rick as the villain of the season but
they sort of brought him back from that
because I feel like the show doesn't
work if you make Rick a legit villain
that's why you have people like evil
Morty to be the real villain they just
want to show you how Rick can become a
villain not that he is the ultimate
villain but just look at the laundry
list of powerful characters that he's
able to mow over when he gets super
drunk like he doesn't even have to think
about it he doesn't even remember that's
how casual it was for him to defeat
world ender in the writers did this
really funny thing where they were
hyping up world ender before the episode
like oh I don't know he's gonna be
really dangerous
like he's meant to be this Thanos level
villain that Rick defeats while he's
super drunk we actually introduced a new
villain this season that's going to be
bigger and badder than any other
character you've seen in the Rick and
Morty's diverse thus far and his name is
world ender
he is a giant hulking beast of a monster
who if you think like danos [ __ ]
Darkseid and like had a baby and that
baby then [ __ ] some other a giant
creature monster that's world alright
short mission good mission remember when
Alan wanted to use a ghost train so just
based on the way things that played out
c-137 rick is still the most powerful
character in every reality but there are
a lot of bonus picks that didn't quite
make it onto the list because they were
able to beat Rick in really funny ways
the biggest ones being Jerry like Rick
actually concedes to Jerry he's unable
to beat him because he loves his family
even though he has trouble saying it in
so many words jerry is able to beat Rick
through his incredible mediocrity Jerry
you win no amount of genius can stop
your dumb mediocre vacuous roots from
digging into everything and everyone
around you and draining them of any
ability to fend you off so then you have
people like toxic Rick detoxified Morty
like American Psycho wolf of Wall Street
Morty looks like he could do just about
anything like this is a proto version of
evil Morty or mr. poopy butthole who's
one of the few characters that knows
that he's inside a TV show which is
automatically makes him a very powerful
character but you've never actually seen
him face off against the characters
which is why I put him on the bonus list
and not on the actual top ten list but
just let me know in the comments who are
your favorite most powerful characters
in the multiverse and what will happen
is is they'll be new Rick and Morty next
week it was a little crazy this past
week because a bunch of shows came back
but quick update to the saga of Szechuan
sauce like I said in my last Szechuan
video which I'll link at the end of this
MacDonald said it's bringing it back
this winter for free I read something
about somebody trading their old car for
a packet of Szechuan sauce please do not
pay a lot of money on ebay for Szechuan
sauce they'll literally be giving it
away later this year so no worries
speaking of which there is a new round
of the merge giveaway for Zen monkey
studios all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video congratulations to the winner from
the last video noob noob please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so we can get your contact details you
can click here for that Szechuan video
in
for what's happening and when it's
coming back and you can click here for
all the big trailers that drop yesterday
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]